gorgeous evening here on the mountain
people seem to be having such a good
time I think it's definitely a few
people with a few glasses of wine in
hand ready to pull their night ahead as
they camp out on the mile including
these two ladies here hello how are you
feeling about camping out overnight
ahead of the big day tomorrow it's a bit
of an adventure we've never done it
before and the upstairs just Electric
I think it's the
is that she's behind us really so
don't worry that someone was coming
through your sitting room because we've
got everyone's got dens haven't they
they've claimed their sport we've got
our little lounges that everyone has and
why was it so important to camp out to
be here all day ahead of tomorrow for
the king to come past he's our King and
he deserves it yes
yes very simple
because both of you I know you said to
me you've both been to a number of very
important Royal events before how old do
you think this will compare to some of
the other ones
anything like this because I haven't
camped out I've just sort of done seeing
the queen lying in state and that's
about it and that was very somber
um it was a long night nine hours
uh this is really sort of this is more
fun yeah it's fun and it's Child's Play
and we sat down yes well I hope you are
both able to get some sleep tonight I
think it might be tricky for a few
people it'll be a bit noisy thank you
very much for speaking to us and I hope
you have a good day tomorrow because
this is very much where the action will
be happening at 20 past 10 tomorrow
where King Charles will leave Buckingham
Palace and make his way along the mall
to Westminster Abbey